[Music]
Singapore is a truly international city
there are four official languages but
you'll hear dozens more on the streets
of this island city-state half the
population is temporary stopping in to
work or study for short stints and that
constant coming and going creates a
vibrant mix of cultures
[Music]
tucked under Malaysia Singapore was only
founded in 1965 it's now one of the
richest nations in the world and a
global financial hub Singapore invested
a whopping 1 billion dollars in startups
and 37 thousand international companies
are based here the first thing you need
to know about Singapore is it's not all
work the city now claims six of the
world's best bars plus 47 Michelin stars
[Music]
so let's start here at the swanky Atlas
bar front and centre is the colossal gin
tower packed with over 1000 varieties
this Art Deco bar opened last year and
was quickly rated in the world's top 20
but if you're looking for something a
little less shouty
then head over to d bespoke
the Ginza style bar is regularly rated
one of the best cocktail spots in the
city it's sleek and sumptuous interior
draws in a sharply dressed crowd but you
don't have to spend a fortune to enjoy
the breaths of what Singapore has to
offer the city-state has three major
ethnic groups Chinese Malay and Indian
to have a taste of the more traditional
and colorful side of Singapore plan a
day trip to the cultural enclaves of
Chinatown Little India or the Arab
quarter but if you want to eat where the
chef's choose to eat try this burnt ends
is not a good option for vegetarians it
specializes in grilled meats and has
become a favorite local and visiting
chefs set up by two Australians this
modern barbecue restaurant is famous for
its open kitchen and superheated coal
oven it's actually illegal to rent out
private homes in Singapore so stick to
hotels this is the Hyatt and as hotel
one of many luxury options we have saved
what's probably Singapore's most famous
hotel and bar for last and that's
because you can't get in there at the
moment
raffles hotel is where the Singapore
sling was invented and its reopening in
the fall of 2018 after a massive
reconstruction
finally if you find yourself with some
down time go to see the audacious
gardens by the bay populated with giant
super trees these structures are really
huge Hanging Gardens
the total cost of this public park was 1
billion dollars part of a push by
Singapore to transform into what they
call a city in a garden
[Music]
you